cast alia c'est le nom du futur centre
aqualudique porté par les villes de
maurepas elancourt débuté avec un peu de
retard les travaux avancent pour
l'instant comme prévu on a passé toutes
les phases d'autorisations
administratives etc qui sont passées
pendant cette période qu vide qu'on a
connu on va livrer à l'été 2022 pour une
activité commerciale a connu dit que
l'important c'est d'ouvrir en été on
respecte cinq bassins dédiés à des
usages variés dont un en extérieur qui
commence à prendre forme dans le
chantier apprentissage baignade sport
santé ou bien être objectif répondre aux
attentes de chacun de manière justement
être sur un équipement qui sera d'abord
durable et qui répond vraiment aux
besoins des différents types d'usagés
que soient les scolaires les
associations ou le grand public manière
générale qui cherchent à avoir une
activité soit sportive soit de détente
soit lui dit carrément il est entouré
d'arbres c'est vraiment dans un écrin de
verdure donc très profitable pour les
habitants qui habitent à côté et qui
profiteront en même temps de toute la
verdure qui autour un projet qui mêle
technologies et environnement à hauteur
de 24 millions d'euros dont la majorité
est fournie par le concessionnaire
le financement public est estimé à 11
millions d'euros il est réparti entre
plusieurs acteurs c'est un bel exemple
de partenariat entre la région qui en
soutien d'un projet de territoire
donc avec l'agglomération effectivement
avec la commune avec le département et
c'est la façon dont nous travaillons
maintenant systématiquement sur tout un
tas de projets la région aide ainsi à
hauteur de 800 mille euros en tant que
porteur du projet l'apport de maurepas
s'élève à 4 millions quatre cent
cinquante mille euros dont un million
quatre cent cinquante mille apportée par
saint quentin en yvelines la ville
d'elancourt rapporte quant à elle 2
millions neuf cent soixante cinq mille
euros pour les futurs nageurs l'entrée a
castagna ne sera pas aussi élevé les
résidents des deux communes paieront 5
euros 40 pour les autres le tarif sera
de 6 euros 95